I mean Marie Curie was extraordinary
through-and-through she won two Nobel
prizes
and I think it's sort of in a way from
the heat the great forces you win won
and you're not satisfied so you win it
in physics you retrain in chemistry and
you win it again I think that's pretty
pretty cool but there it has so much
relevance and importance her win because
you know originally she was not on the
nomination it was only back row and her
husband Pierre Curie who was on the
nomination and her husband stood up for
as very few men would have at that time
in the early today and said you know if
there's a nobel prize to be won then
we're both going to be on that
nomination and and he had it changed you
know because really the the the pursuit
of radioactivity they did discover it
together but it was her notion that led
them into their you know hours and hours
of study and careful manual labor and
careful scientific brain work and and
that it was it was her notion that let
the whole thing erupt in the fail Murray
says that she thinks people have
difficulty separating her work and her
private life I'm intrigued how much do
you think that was the issue at hand and
how much is that still an issue for
women today well I think this is a
problem today but this is very
interesting to to realize that the thing
that we actually attribute to men like
for example we will say this is a very
difficult character you know this is not
a very likeable person but he's a genius
so he's a genius he has a right to be
not likable he's has a right to be a
difficult character this seemed to
accept it very easily for men when it
comes to women our first quality has to
be our sweetness and our kindness yet
you know like I don't know myself the
people I know the women that I know and
all these sweet is like the among the
five first
adjectives that I will qualify them with
so this is this image of of the women
the eternal female and the fool affirmed
and you know in all the cultures so yes
and you know back in 1880 to have a man
who was a wife who to be
his equal his companion you know that
would they will share their work etc
that is somehow very modern and even for
today is very modern so yes they did she
was very modern
he was very modern and the couple even
for today is a very modern couple yes
hundred percent I mean I think Marie and
Pierre Curie had a very inspiring
marriage at any point in history I think
you know they charmed one another they
were sort of independent they didn't
really need outside influence
they were completely satisfied in love
and work and they changed the world
together I mean III find it it sort of
fills me with optimism and a kind of
sort of magical glow and I think about
what it must have felt like that night
when you know after the sort of ultimate
all-nighter as I see it they actually
isolated radium for the first time and
saw that it glowed green I mean can you
imagine that moment where you're holding
almost the future of the human race in
your hands but you don't know it and how
magical and incandescent that little
moment must have been you know it's
almost like knowing that you hold
something and it could change the world
but as yet it's just yours I mean I find
it so beautiful and profound and of
course you know then it did it did it
did sort of that the film is really our
film radioactive is not just a biography
of Marie Curie it's a biography of
radioactivity and you know the fallout
from that moment that moment where
everything was precious and perfect to
when it's no longer in your control and
the phenomenon that is obviously
incredibly powerful and incredibly
important also has you know very very
dangerous potential it's it's very
awesome
it's very awe-inspiring and she was also
a mother of two which is something the
movie dwells on that the difference
between Mary the scientist and Mary the
mother do you think that's central to
understanding her character and also the
way that society treats treats women
differently as mothers I don't think
she's a very she's certainly not a role
model ism
I feel I mean maternal and when you I
mean the thing that you say about her
motherhood sure has this say this big
book where she has measured her kids
like like she measure everything she's
observed
yes so very precisely you know the
length from here to here from the head
like everything that she has a very
scientific way of loving her kids but
again you know you cannot be a
magnificent scientist a perfect spouse a
perfect mother you know today has only
24 hours like even Superman came out
make all of that in one so yeah
obviously when you're dis passionated
and this focus these are the things that
you you cannot be the best at everything
yeah later in life you look back on it
and you can say I wasn't the best mother
I think you know our film has never
tried to make a paragon of virtue out of
madam Kelly because if she was if she
was sweet and lightness and the perfect
mother and a brilliant so she wouldn't
be Madame Curie she might be your you
know your wife or girlfriend but you
know with we have to deal with someone
with floors as well as brilliance
because that's what makes the person I
for me so interesting and it's it's
discovering the flaws and the
realization of those and the regrets and
the things you did wrong I mean one of
the most moving bits the film to me is
when she you know because she was
passionate but didn't always have time
to indulge it and after Pierre's death
when she says confesses to poor daughter
how that you know Pierre Curie once said
to her I could never imagine a life
before I met you and she remembers that
she never said anything back and she can
never get that moment back and it's gone
you know it's we don't have a woman with
regrets I think I haven't got a real
woman and do you think that today women
particularly women in power held to a
different standard a different account
than their male counterparts well of
course they of course their differences
because we have behind us you have 5000
years of culture so you know you cannot
just raise that in five days five years
you know it takes a long time but there
are things that you know
it's the perpetrator society makes an
image of the woman and the image of the
man so there are things that are
acceptable for a woman for example she
can be sensitive she can cry but if a
man cries this is unacceptable it goes
also in the other way but you know like
sometimes I have heard about myself you
know your look so bossy but I'm not
bossy I'm just a boss so I'm just
behaving like the job that I have I have
I have to do that so you know if I'm
angry then I become emotional so you
know and next is that I have hormonal
problems you know I mean men they have
hormonal problem too but they would
never relate that to their hormones when
it comes to women as always the hormone
comes first
so et cetera et cetera so you know and
we don't advance always you know like we
advance sometimes and we go back
sometimes like in our film I know that
Madame Curie was it was much easier for
her at her time to make her side studies
that it was for her daughter because you
had this window of freedom between 1900
and 1910 and then that was closed again
after the first world war you just see
the number of you know this clinic that
make abortion animal in America for
example closing we are not saying that
the women that are getting more rights
and more freedom when you close this
this kind of Center so yeah we just
don't it depends very much at a time in
the world so now for example in a very
are in a very conservative time so
obviously as as soon as it is
conservative the women they have to
suffer from it so you know we will
celebrate a man who will become a father
at the age of 75 and we're say oh great
well I mean this we can discuss that but
you know like a woman who has a younger
boyfriend then they called it could
there is a name what do they call this
women that they have younger boyfriend
they yes
cougar so we say a woman is a cougar but
a man who is with a younger woman is not
the lie and we don't call him like any
kind of animal so yeah there differences
but that that's it I mean it's also our
responsibility we as women to change
that because you know we can complain
about the men attitude but until we
embrace that
and we perpetuate that because like in
this patriarchal schema who is teaching
the value to his kids
is the mother so we have we have the
responsibility to raise them up
differently we have to give them your
power to believe that they can do
anything as human beings
yeah because also when women have
swallowed the patriarchal system in the
patriarchal narrative and that's you
know they're raising it and they're
judging other women accordingly not by
you know it takes a long time to free
yourself from you don't realize how many
constructs are in your brain because of
that narrative and your expectations I
mean you know for even you know the way
that something like the Daily Mail will
you know always remark if they're
telling a story on how old the woman is
and the man you know sometimes it's
humorous you ex woman 53 with ex woman
23 and this man blasts you know whatever
and the man's nature is never mentioned
but it's it's women who were asking for
the age to be declared it's men don't
give a toss about it actually it's the
it's other women who want to know and
judge themselves measure themselves and
judge themselves accordingly and that's
what's you know I think that's part of
what's got to change as well you know we
can change the world if we don't change
ourselves basically this is it you know
we cannot ask you know because while we
are going to gain freedom the men they
will lose stuff so there is why would
they lose you know like clapping in
their hand being very happy so you know
all rights we have to go and take it but
we have to be conscious of it and we
have to behave accordingly so we cannot
always blame the other one I think it's
time for us you know to wake up
ourselves and see how do we behave what
can we make it and what examples do we
give to the girls you know and Marie
Curie gives a very good one because she
lived equality she took it as her right
you know I didn't she was too busy to
sort of fight for it she just owned it
she she went by her herself as a brain
as a scientist you know and as a
scientist she was equal and that's all
that really mattered you know she knew
that if you take two human bodies and
you know after death you dissect them
and you take out the brain there's no
difference between a mask
brain and a feminine brain and that is
how she lived and factually there is no
difference this is facts that science
clearly the films about the world of
science but the film industry has
recently been rocked by the me to
movement do you think that's a watershed
moment for the industry and for society
and do you think that's what we need to
finally shift the narrative well you
know when when when we started making
radioactive you know just even not go to
the meet you and the feminist movement
as a matter of fact we are half of the
population in the world you know this is
mathematics so it's very normal that
half of the story of the world would be
about us but this is not the fact this
is number one then if that is about us
were always related through someone so
you start with somebody's daughter and
then girlfriend and then you're the wife
and then you're the mother and then
you're the woman who has been cheating
on and that you become the grandmother
and this is how it goes it's very rare
to have this kind of thing this kind of
film so this is this is factual and this
is also factual that you know like if
you're a woman and a man and you're in
Hollywood and you have the same
competences they will trust more a man
to give him the money that I don't know
why I tend to give it to the woman this
is all also something but again you know
if we want you know like nomination if
you want presence we have to be also
extremely present you know you cannot
make a few films by women and half of
half of the nomination the real question
is that why don't we have more film
directed by women well the reason is
that how many girls do believe in
themselves to become directors so this
is a change of culture and that is a
much deeper deeper subject but that you
have to fight that from the root so
these movements they're great and I
think they opened the eyes of many
people and you know I heard somebody
told me oh that is going to be now all
this mediocre film made by mediocre
women well you know for 100 years
mediocre men made lots of mediocre film
so what happened nothing that's it
Osment he recently played the journalist
Mary Colvin another woman who in her own
way changed the world and was equally
powerful there's no coincidence you're
choosing these roles is it well I'm
actually interested in women who speak
the truth to power and I think if
anything comes out of the mute to
movement it's that it's that girls are
going to have the courage to do that in
our industry you know I'm certainly the
young girl that I'm working with now on
the series I'm shooting I'm encouraging
through them to do that at every turn
you know something's not right
speak up about it don't say you know
I've got to do this sex scene on Monday
and nobody's discussed it with me
make sure someone discusses it with you
or don't show up you know make sure you
have that conversation make sure you're
protected you know speak your truth to
power and Mary Colvin did that she she
voiced she gave a voice to the to the
voiceless she found the most vulnerable
people on earth and and and told the
truth about their suffering and Marie
Curie spoke the truth to power at every
turn she went before the French
government and said this is what we you
know your your system is shoddy men are
being you know men are dying on your
battlefields unnecessarily they're being
amputated without you cause let me have
my mobile x-ray units and I will show
you a different way to do things you
know so I think the things I'm drawn to
a courage and speaking one's truth is
why we want to work with her because you
know you need an intelligent fierce
woman and then of course you want to
work with Rosa this is the result of I'm
intrigued to see what you do next
oh well as she's fictional the character
I'm doing at the moment but still I
tried
hopefully I'll bring the same qualities
to bear yeah we have a common project we
do you yes we'll bring it up yes we're
working on something
watch this faith